greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by zip recruiter listen hiring used to
be hard multiple job sites tax a resumes
confusing review process
but today iron can be easy and you can
only have one place to get it done you
ready for this
zip recruiter dot-com slash Church zip
recruit is so effective that four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day what are you gonna get that listen
it's all about saving time and right now
you could get zip recruiter for free
what are you talking to my Joe it's
Monday listen for free all you gotta do
is go to Zipporah google.com slash
church and they'll let you try out zip
recruiter calm the smartest way to hire
right now like I said zip recruiter for
free the church family go to zip
recruiter right now
so the zip recruit is smartest way to
hire it's Monday the 16th of March for
starters I'm very sorry about Nyack on
Thursday night I'm very sorry I had to
cancel but listen I'm the last guy that
wants to get anybody I don't go take
people down dark streets I don't
I like the if I go down a dark street I
go by myself I've been like that for 57
years you know the thing is in New
Rochelle it's growing like a pimple and
and and you know it's ten minutes from
there from Nyack I'm not there was no
way first of all I was supposed to go
back to shoot a movie right I was gonna
go back and I was supposed to shoot
today and tomorrow so a lot of the
podcast you've been listening to have
been pre-recorded because I thought I
was going to be gone for ten days but
what happened was huh my knee had been
hurtin for like the last six months my
knees been hurtin everything hurts I'm
getting old but I called my doctor my
knee doctor doctor Nicola and I went
down and they did x-rays they did an MRI
my thry this and my knees is really bad
so he said the right one was worse than
the left one so he's gonna shoot me in
the right one first with this Nova Sisk
it's like a gel that goes in between
your knee and and the foams in there too
loose you know to lighten up the pain of
arthritis but he ordered two shots but
he said he was only gonna give me one
because sometimes you get a real
allergic reaction oh [ __ ] look at my leg
it's still bruised and that was a week
ago yesterday so when Tuesday morning
when I woke up in my leg he told me he's
only gonna give you one in case you got
in a la an allergic reaction to it right
so I go down and Monday shoots me in the
knee I don't pass out nothing my wife
drives me back it's a good day and I I
don't think we did anything Monday I
think I just relaxes I didn't know I
didn't want to put anybody in a bad
position if I made plans and I didn't
know if I was passed out so I got home
but Tuesday morning when I woke up my
knee was swollen and I didn't even know
it I got up and went to boxing oh hi box
for an hour I went then did drills and
the whole thing and after class that's
when the teacher said you know your
knees be bruised right and I go no and I
looked at it and the whole side of it
was purple over the band-aid I still had
left the back I forgot I even got the
shot on Tuesday morning I don't know
what that was wrong with me and I got
home I called the doctor and he goes
it's gonna swell up and right away he
goes just put ice on it and don't fly
for a couple days I'm like oh no but by
Monday after I listened to the Rogan
podcast that was the best podcast yeah
he ever did in his life and just the
fact that he called me afterwards and
explained to me that he was having the
same doubts I was having because I
listen I got a GED man I'm not a genius
but I knew last Monday that New York was
gonna be bad I'm in it I spent three
weeks in New York and May and that had
been the first time I had spent quality
time in the city and
25 years so I didn't know what the city
was about and me and my wife were having
a conversation two days ago and I'm in
my second week on the set of The
Sopranos
I had Tuesday off I had just returned
from 4/20 I went to Milwaukee and I was
smoking those rapists ok pens for some
reason I got vapours to go to New York
and I had a headache so that Monday I
still remember I was across the street
from the garden and during the day they
have like a little thing on the side of
the street in the garden it's like food
trucks you could buy your food in this
building right and go outside they got
tremendous steak Sam which is they got
everything in that nice it's like a
little lunch place then you go outside
and sit on the side of the garden
there's a street and there was a
beautiful day it was April 22nd you know
whatever it was and I'm sitting there
I'm like man I'm talking to my wife and
my wife remembered the conversation and
I go you know what man there's a lot of
people walking the streets you know what
if and she goes what do you mean I can't
imagine my Godzilla attacking or
somebody dropping a bomb here we had
this conversation yeah so when I saw the
map Tuesday and I shouldn't saw New
Rochelle had already been contaminated
and whatnot I'm like this is easy to
pull the plug well the scariest thing
for me about that broken podcast was
everyone saying I'll wash your hands
wash your hands and the thing is
transmitted through your breath through
your mouth so there's no way you feel
like you can wash your hands all day it
doesn't mean anything you know what man
but I'd rather be safe than sorry oh
yeah I don't touch my unit unless I wash
my hands I'm one of those guys even
without the list like normal even
without this I don't touch my unit
unless I wash my hands whether I'm at an
airport I've been doing this fees you
don't to put your you into somebody's
mouth and they got germs no I've been
vigilant about this since day one you
know it doesn't take a genius you know I
went to Atlanta on the 24th and I saw
all the invasion of Asians at the
airport nothing
against them I'm not saying nothing
along and then I went to Vegas on the
twenty no that has to be dead
a February Vegas is at 14% this weekend
Vegas is shutting down today
casinos shut down today Airlines will
probably shut down tomorrow that's it
but when I woke up Wednesday
I called her Tuesday night and told them
the truth because I wasn't supposed to
shoot till Monday there was no reason
for me to be lurking around the city on
the ferries or whatnot
there was no reason for me wait and once
I saw my knee swollen I just called them
up and I said listen I'm not coming in
today I'm coming in Saturday so I
switched to my Saturday we would know I
knew for a fact they called me back and
said they were gonna fly me in Sunday
with Jon Bernthal we were gonna fly in
shoot the movie and fly back on Tuesday
night after the movie there was gonna be
no wasted time but I knew Thursday that
this wasn't happening
they were already starting to shut TV
shows they were starting to shut a bunch
of stuff and then Friday I got the call
in the afternoon that they pulled down
production that's it that's what I was
wondering i was wondering if i keeping
like cuz i they never canceled post when
I was working in post ever so I'm
wonderful shutting that stuff down
well post you work by yourself yeah but
I'm still right you by yourself you're
fine
post is fine they don't want you to be
in a big circle I mean listen I an
office is in office every office is
filthy yeah there's nothing you could do
about that even our little office just
plunger germs in here just from us
that's why I came in here last week like
two nights I wiped everything down and
we brought extra wipes me and mercy came
in one night we wiped everything now we
spray we sprayed the couches you know I
knew last week I knew last week this is
not you know am I scared no I'm not
scared but I'm prepared I'm 57 you guys
have been hearing me for years you guys
make fun of my
my [ __ ] emphysema you guys know I have
like mild them I have the beginnings of
emphysema from smoking because I'm 12 so
I felt right now the age group yeah I'm
not doing it I'm not doing it I'm not I
know I'm not getting on a plane you know
right now where people do not realize is
that every day we shut down people are
gonna hurt you see what happened on
JetBlue oh yeah a guy this is why this
is why because it's not what you do it's
what other people do around you so
before that happens just shut it down
yeah I knew March 2nd I wasn't going
back to the store when I went to the
store on March 2nd after my Vegas trip
yeah and they told me that Vegas was at
50% that weekend February 29th
Vegas was at 50% Wow even though we sold
out thank you very much we were at 50%
Las Vegas the whole city of Las Vegas so
when I got back that was when the scare
start again a little bit more I could
see the airport was dead you know and I
remember going to that Comedy Store
Tuesday night and I had two shows and
I'm going into that main room the Sarah
Melo show and she had 20 people in that
green room and my anxiety shot up my
anxiety shot up I got out of that I went
to the hallway and I stayed there by the
door and I breathed and I made a mental
note not to go back down there until
they figured one thing we figured out
what this was
thank God The Comedy Store you know is
they're geniuses and they said we're
closing they're down we know we know
what I told them I said Tuesdays and
Thursdays and Wednesday's is half
international audience it's a death
sentence for us yeah you know it's an
international audience I have nothing
against them I'm glad they come in
support and they come to the Comedy
Store and they see the beauty that I see
but at the same time we all have to
protect ourselves
I've had every every show except for one
next week all the way to the middle
label has been cancelled yeah there's no
there's no reason there's no reason I
have you know Santa Barbara's obviously
canceled I'm very sorry we will make
that up some other time of the year I'm
not worried about it
April I have Reno and Portland
Portland's already been canceled nobody
knows what they're gonna do a Reno but I
doubt I'm gonna get on a plane it's it's
over for me for my age it's over so what
we'll do is what I'm gonna do is when I
come back is lower my ticket prices back
to $25 you know because when I get back
on the road I'm alone 25 bucks that's it
we're gonna go through a hard time in
this country we're gonna go through
whether it's one week two weeks three
weeks four weeks we're gonna suffer yeah
on the first week that we're open at the
store we're probably gonna do benefits
for the waitstaff and for the employees
The Comedy Store the gentlemen they're
gonna pay everybody but I told the
Comedy Store that our first weekend we
should just be doing benefits for the
waitstaff
because they got used to a certain
lifestyle also on there's kids and they
have families also so that's the first
thing we're doing at the store is
benefits for the work work the wait
staff and the people employees who you
know how those people live off tips yeah
you know what about you know minimum
wage people going to CVS corners of
course like you said they're shutting
down the grocery store now early that's
a whole shift of people that's gone it's
uh I don't I remember when I first moved
here you do that math me like I only
have a week left of of money to think
about having a month with no work I'll
imagine if you just moved to LA you can
sell in September after graduating like
it's pretty crazy I can't imagine the
don't you know just the effects of all
this I just can't imagine it and my
heart goes out to America my heart goes
out to the world I know what it is to
struggle I know what it is you know so
this is what I'm thinking about again
I'm very sorry about Nayak but man I
couldn't live with myself if I saw that
somebody got affected during one of my
shows or that they went to a show and
they all went to an improv that night
and now my name goes I'm negatively like
that cuz I wanted to make a few [ __ ]
dollars that's not what it's about this
is not the time to do [ __ ] stand-up
or to put other people's lives at risk I
will not I don't listen I don't like
people breathing on my neck you see how
I get I don't even like people stand
next to me you know you go with me to a
restaurant yeah you see when they sit
next to people I always tell away enough
go why we the restaurant is empty and
you got me on top of a couple that's
nice people they're gonna hear us two
gorillas talking about the language I
talk now I'm like I don't like being
around people that's one thing I never
liked is sitting on top of people
sitting next to people I've always hated
that stuff so flying you know I don't
know what's gonna happen right now and
I'm a big way I almost never cook but I
haven't cooked since last week I don't
trust I I mean it's hard to trust
anybody now me talking about you don't
eat out since last week right I don't
know I'm only crying I've never cooked I
have only been cooking since last week I
don't trust any of these restaurants
it's not the trust is you rather be safe
than sorry
you still gotta support a couple these
places just take your food to go like
they're doing in Hoboken the restaurants
are staying open look they have a date I
was gonna ask you about that they have a
curfew
and although yeah ten time they're gonna
have a curfew everywhere pretty soon I
think so yeah for a couple weeks man for
a couple weeks
you got a support listen I got a still
support cactus
I still got a support sushi Dan some way
you know those are my restaurants I
still gotta support the barbecue place I
don't go there a lot you know
I'll try to do privates or something at
the gym once this dies down this week
it's gonna be punching a bag in the back
yard and doing kettlebells yeah I'm not
going into no gym or anything like that
you know and people liked what I kept
hearing from people was all this happens
every four years before an election it
does it does it does
but as this look this happened to you in
your lifetime I can't remember anything
like I don't I don't remember seeing
anything like this in my life what you
know what listen man you can't get
depressed you can't let it get you down
you know why because you can't control
this guys you can't control this this is
beyond your control
so before you get depressed and go into
a funk and get skinned and whatever
listen I'd rather you get a notebook and
start writing what you're feeling
cuz if you don't think I was going
through this last week when I the fear I
had a go on in New York I cannot tell
you and it wasn't New York or the state
of the people it was being on those
planes what have I always said four
years you got to assume they don't do
not they don't clean they don't get what
they don't care Pete these people do not
care anymore
you know this was uh I think this was a
wake-up call these people were getting
greedy and acting greedy I mean Jesus
Christ you're trying not to you still
want to have a fight Dana White and then
English you know it just it just never
ends you gotta think of people you gotta
think of a guy behind you you gotta
think of a guy in front of you gotta
think of a guy next to you I know yeah
how many toilet paper rolls do you need
and it's pretty crazy I went to this
Walgreens DNA and I know the girl there
you know I always go there
I wanna let you go this is the first
time I saw you buy something the hell
are the nicotine gum because I don't
like ten note books you know I went to
Walgreens and bought some stuff and she
goes you know I've never seen people's
behavior it really teaches your people
all about yeah this is the time when
you're more human these are the times
when you stop the people more you know
check on people more you know it's gonna
cost you a couple dollars it's gonna
cost me a couple dollars
of course everybody a couple dollars I'm
prepared but I don't want none of my
friends to go without either you know
this is gonna be a time this is uh it's
not a joke but I don't want you to get
down because you can't control this you
cannot control this you cannot control
this this was way beyond your control
I know you wanted to get married April
4th I know you wanted to have a big
wedding but it don't look like it
because you got grandparents and you got
parents and you got people you invited
over the age of 50 and that's acceptable
to this so you can't think about you I
don't care what you would think of our
there was a lady yesterday on the news
and they came from New Zealand and she
was like wow you know we came all the
way here for an extended weekend what a
waste did the poor [ __ ] kid you were
with go to Disneyland two days yeah then
that's enough that's enough so the kid
was complaining because he couldn't go
to Disneyland yesterday in LA so you
went Thursday and Friday yeah that's
enough little kid be satisfied thank God
thank God Disneyland that's a germ bomb
that's a German bomb that's a German
bomb listen I go to New York this is no
joke this is no not to make a laugh
anything like this this is how
susceptible like I'm ammo about two
years ago I was having a conversation
with mine oh my god
like I wish I had the opportunity to
smoke with Snoop Dogg and I was like why
do people think I don't want to smoke
with anybody like I've never wanted to
smoke with anybody I knew when I was 13
so that I would smoke in large circles I
would get sick well my friends would
smoke in large circles I would have to
think about what I was doing I would get
sick so by the age of 15 I already knew
not to smoke in large circles so when I
went on it would be me of the low lubes
you know I'd be like three of us we
would go through 20 numbers we go
through a half of those
but it would be three of us and once you
build the time as to each three is you
could smoke all the time
but I'm not gonna go to Kentucky and
smoke with people that was never gonna
happen
I made that mistake in the beginning
like in the very beginning when I went
out to Utah and stuff and I got sick and
then it brought me back to what happened
to Ralphy when he got his lungs he got
bronchitis and I stopped smoking people
a long time ago when I go down to the
comedy store on Tuesday nights and I see
Gina from speed weenie gives me a number
I don't share it with nobody nobody gets
that I spoke by myself I don't care who
gets mad because I'm the one that gets
acceptable for that stuff yeah that's my
bomb you know that's my bomb pretty much
he was mining yours you quit smoking
that's my bomb I cleaned that thing out
you got to see the bomb in my house and
spotless tip-top Magoo I got to bring
this one home and clean it the way I
clean the one at the house as it has
been a while since I claimed it there oh
but now I'm more cautious than ever I'm
not gonna get on no five and a half
hours like not for a while not for a
while it makes you think about how much
like I didn't think about this and
someone mentioned it online
Oh what are you getting gas I never once
wiped that thing down oh yeah this is so
much thinking my car got paper towels
first I really think it's something
about healthy people right now when you
were a sweatshirt when you go to the
store cover your hand with the
sweatshirt tell me that your and then
you gotta wash your sweatshirt so when I
go home tonight this sweatshirt will get
washed this is the way I'm living the
next couple of weeks every day the
sweatshirt gets washed the sweatpants
get washed if I sit on a park bench or
something gets washed you know I've been
gone in the park over here and just to
walk around just to loosen up because
that's it you know I wanted to reduce
stress I wanted to so I just been
walking around but now everything gets
washed every day everything every hooded
sweatshirt I change with it sweatshirts
every day I throw them in the hamper
until this is over
and this is gonna be a crucial week
America
and the world how you know that but what
am I saying America there's gonna be a
crucial week this week and next week a
very crucial I hope so I mean that guy
the Rogan podcast it was a couple months
yeah
but these next two weeks are how we
control everything
these next two weeks how we're gonna be
able to stop this you know and I know
the way I factory still open and the
Icehouse store good for them as far as
I'm concerned like I told your rogue and
I'm starting from scratch I'm done I'm
done
yeah done done I will I just went I
think I told you I bought 10 new
notebooks cuz I'm starting from scratch
this is just a great time to write and
if you keep that muscle active we'll be
fine
hopefully this week we'll come down here
one night and do a little a little
stand-up comedy and get the party
started and that's it that's basically
it you know it's funny it's just uh you
have to be cautious like do your friends
back home who stuff to work every day
yeah like your UPS what do you mean yeah
what are they were they saying I haven't
talked to my buddy from Federal Express
you know I've spoken to George I spoken
the Timmy you know Timmy's a truck
driver so they're by themselves
somebody loads the truck for them they
pull up get out and somebody unload the
truck okay Thanks so that's good he
doesn't lose any money and I know and
speaking of which
especially planes down thank God for all
the truck drivers with all the grocery
stores empty right now
I guess if that got shut down can you
imagine thank God for what we do have
just be thankful for what you do have
stop complaining and like I said this is
something that's beyond your control
this doesn't reflect on you you know if
you got to stay in for a weekend a TV
dinner so be it
this doesn't reflect on you right now
this is what they're calling for is to
have the least amount a contact with
people I've been trying to I'm puffing
that much no you're more of the weed
store no no don't you say a little
louder dummy that's why I said off
because she's here no I haven't that
much do they is it all contained like do
they have to touch it there no I don't
know okay I have not been puffing that
smile I know what they don't crazy and I
got I got so much stuff at the house
I'll need to go anyway I'm good to go
I'm good to go well at least you
prepared you have to be this is it you
have to be but I haven't been puffing
this much I've been eatin edibles I've
been down in the edibles throughout the
day time to calm me down a little bit
and that's all you can do you know I'd
rather be up and down I didn't want to
go down and for a while there last week
I was starting to go down and I can feel
myself and I caught myself like thirds
that I said no like I said I had a
really weird incident the night of the
UFC fight right with Chang and Johanna
and Romero and the other one yeah my
anxiety level was so high that night
that I had to force myself to go out to
watch the fight at a friend's house the
anxiety about for you well you saw this
coming
I just felt something that I hadn't felt
since I was a kid you know when I came
from Cuba
it was 1966 and from the time I went
there like first grade kindergarten
second grade there was always talk of
the Russians attacking us yeah so we had
a thing called the fallout shelter in
this country you have rows every
building had Wow
you had fallout shelters when you walked
into a building and actually had this
sign that had like a circle with a
nuclear thing going through it and it
had fallout shelter
and they had like tang rice they added
water to bottled water you know this is
like way before I tank so water I don't
know if it was bottled water but tanks
of water and I remember that fear and it
still didn't me like I still remember
getting like God immunized and all that
stuff I'm telling you to prevent you
from getting this and prevent you from
getting that all that came back like all
that fear from being a kid and it just
just you know listen you know I'm the
type of guy I'm scared of everything as
it is I live in fear so for a couple
days there in had me Friday once I
realized I didn't have to go to New York
and I knew I could control my output
I was happy I'm very happy we went to
the park she's not allowed to touch the
metal so we like I said I'm going to
different parks just to walk get vitamin
D because your immune system is the most
important thing right now so vitamin C
vitamin D breathing getting those lungs
healthy that's the most important thing
on my mind right now and that's what
everybody should be thinking about you
know like when I talk to my friend who
was a cop in Hoboken he was like it was
like people were like nothing was going
on and I don't expect you to become a
hermit I'll expect people to change
their lives drastically but you gotta
try a little bit grow up grow up there
was a girl yesterday from my hometown
that was putting up on Saturday she was
putting up all the party she was going
to and I wish I could have grabbed this
girl by the neck and saying to her you
couldn't be this [ __ ] like Herod ah
ha her husband dumped her for a younger
girl so she's trying to prove now she's
my age she's trying to prove that she
still has something and she I mean I
just look at her Facebook to feel sorry
for because you can't be this
embarrassing she went to every dump bar
in Jersey like I went to high school
with her and she was putting up flyers
like since Wednesday come to club
sensation with DJ Vinnie and like in
like radiation Park New Jersey you know
and like we all know it's like radio you
got you got you know New Jersey's what
cancer was invented out by the
Meadowlands ok Moonachie all that stuff
and now you're gonna add Kovac to it and
I'm gonna go spend it with DJ Vinnie at
some bar are you crazy
I'm surprised he didn't call bomb
threats oh my god I was so frustrated
and everywhere she went she put a video
up and the places were dead oh yes the
places were dead and she's like pushed
her like look at us having a good time
and she showed her girlfriend who was a
mortadella
like I wouldn't even a step out of the
house of the girl she was with between
her and the girl they could stop bird
[ __ ] minute
that's how ugly they both are there was
just votes in there and all these young
guys around like nobody's gonna hit on
you go home go home what are you doing
at this bar in Hackensack New Jersey
with a bunch of guys listen to a CD
sighs shook me all night long oh my god
that was the most embarrassing thing
they should alright not one of those 19
people want to live you can tell they
had that on their mind you can tell
they're out there drinking and huggin
each other my new people don't want to
live I could tell cuz you cannot be in a
bar like that no I could not believe
that yesterday she went to mount one bar
she put up like six videos I saw them
last night I called my wife in the
office I go this is a chick that'll be
dead in ten days look at I'm gonna be
jumping up and down I'm the first one I
send the roses because you can't be this
done like I can see going out for a
purpose like if you got a purpose but
you're going to dive bars than a filthy
and northern Jersey those bars are
filthy filthy
we're like moving here I don't trust
those either no listen there's nowhere
to go we went to the movies last week we
want to see hon word
oh yeah and we wiped everything down we
sat by the by the door there we're by
ourselves there was only 11 people movie
but I was thinking about going to
Arclight last night I'm like no I wasn't
gonna see the you know the movie about
basketball
with the guy from the town what's your
boy from Boston Affleck snow movie okay
and I was like what am i [ __ ] I'm
gonna breathe on myself
no no it's okay two weeks two weeks
can't take off completely two weeks I
gotta I'm not going into a restaurant
I'm ordering I'm opening up the door I'm
putting the doorstop on it so there's
oxygen because that's the most important
thing is there like that's why I said go
to cactus cuz it's outside smart you
know I'll Drive there if I see too many
people I'll Drive right back I've done
that he doesn't I don't I'll stop me
when it's dead well it's completely dead
I have not gotten a cryotherapy since
Wednesday surviving that cold
who virus I don't know what it does but
why check it out white thing again why
find that I don't know what it does and
what it doesn't do do I look like Johnny
scientists do you know so mind your
business you want to get reconditioned
drink milk you know drink a protein
shake that's it there's no cryotherapy
there's nothing that we get to the
bottom of this we should probably be
next week hopefully and I'm pretty
excited
yeah I'm looking what you can look at
this two ways you can look at this from
a negative standpoint and get yourself
sick about it or you could look at it
from a positive standpoint and see a
future for yourself and see that yeah
it's gonna be rough financially but
you're still gonna be alive and that's
what this is all about is you existing
and being a human being so that's fine
it's gonna be rough but if you do the
right steps right now it'll make it
easier later plus there's a lot to do I
have to do my taxes lots of ugly I mean
I just got extended really yeah
taxes don't tell me that I'm a
procrastinator now yeah
taxes got extended a lot of things got
extended then trying to work I just
don't want the American public to think
they gotta get a check in the mail for
five grand that's not gonna happen
nobody's that good so relax
hold on to your money you know we get
refunds on whatever you bought that you
don't want like my tickets get rid of
them get rid of them get your money get
your money back right now I'm telling
you get your $30 back right now cuz I
ain't coming anyway get your money now
like May April get your money back
don't waste your time I'm trying to be
honest with you I got three dates in
April there at the store how hot are
those if I gotta get on a plane it
doesn't look like you're gonna see me
I'm just telling you that right now five
and a half hours to Florida in May I
don't see it get your money back now I
don't see it I don't see it I was very
excited about going to Austin and cent
and El Paso so I saw DFW Airport last
night and I get tossed and get your
money back get your money back kissing
it's not happening honest I do love the
perspective from her elegantly
established comment gonna do like me I'm
like I don't want to cancel I didn't
want to cancel the bar show and you're
looking at the airline you're like
doesn't look good I'm not gonna listen
LAX and Kennedy a bull German German
bombs you know tomorrow when they
announce how many TSA agents got yeah
this and they close the airports that's
that's a different level that means if
you're thinking about Oberyn you better
get a bicycle you better listen the only
people are gonna make money right now I
gotta be Chinese people with the
rickshaws rickshaw business
tomorrow's that day get that mask and
just get a rickshaw run up and down your
street for a few days
practice get those legs in shape because
this has the uber rickshaw that's the
new at selling $7 get you to the moon
you don't saying just keep running money
just keep running dog it's all oh but
the shot that's the new setting you'll
see it tomorrow
uber uber uber rickshaw Habib is showing
up in 2.3 minutes to pick you up you
look up the corn is he a beef running
down the street with 705 dying man I did
not know you lived up here yeah just let
me hop up there and let's get this party
started
wait till they have uber horse that's
come out any day now they just drop a
horse and funny house that's perfect
uber Pony uber horse uber tank wait for
like $12.99 you get a tank from per
minute uber tanks horse and uber
rickshaw right now if you think I'm not
starting a new business and you want to
get in shape or you CrossFitters there
you go no more CrossFit you can spend
your time picking me and Lee up what do
you call that rickshaw that's around
town yeah
how about tip you're heavy I'm happy
with the tip I want to see you make
Laurel Canyon when you got to go up just
make one little Canyon with me and I'll
pay you whatever you want but that's it
that's the future's right now rickshaw
rent that your horse whatever when
you'll see it yeah you'll see it people
start getting smart though somebody's
only got a car but like a little hitch
are you all hitch in the back and you
can sit back that you can breathe and
get Sun well they're already doing that
have you seen the uber drivers have like
they put up panels in their cars so they
can sit there not there like and not
have like the people breathe on them oh
my god that's terrible
yeah
smart so glass like the gallery that's
not glasses like plastics wrong forget
it you get you get the co Vinnie you
drive yourself too you must be is
something hospital right now that
shielding undo nothing to protect my
body but yeah that's it it's gonna be
horseback rickshaw and in tank uber tank
I would love to see you on horseback I
think I think it worked for you listen I
don't need to go anywhere that
desperately you understand me my Subaru
works great no get me there I filled it
up just in case yeah I'm gonna do the
same fill your car up these are just
little things you could do you know it's
funny people well what's gonna happen
with the Netflix festival not that
Netflix is doing Netflix is the only
thing that's people gonna really watch a
lot of Netflix but there's no Netflix
festival now it's a month away
you know people been hitting me up why
aren't you wearing your name on the list
Netflix suck now Netflix offered me a
show the problem is I had to do I'm
doing a show already at The Wiltern in
November so I didn't want to do two
shows at The Wiltern and then [ __ ]
myself
people will hit me up for like three
days so I got tickets for bird eye
coming on the left with Netflix so now
Netflix is a great company Netflix gave
me a great opportunity you know anybody
who put me on this stage gave me a great
opportunity I'm not mad at Netflix not
like that that's why I didn't think the
the the festival didn't take the
festival because I already had a date at
The Wiltern theater the festival came
out of nowhere it's LA and to me there's
a Comedy Festival over every night The
Comedy Store yeah so why would I sign up
her economy first like I'm not knowing
nothing against Netflix I just thought
that I think I had one of the dates
already booked and I just I'm doing The
Wiltern by myself the day before
Thanksgiving why would I worry about
that
so I got no bill regard to nip flex or
whatever I don't know why people were
saying that [ __ ] to me I just figured no
I like you know it's so weird how when I
shot degenerates I was very excited I
was very happy it wasn't till I was
coming home that I realize it was what I
didn't want to do it's so weird well not
when you become a comic like when you
become other an artist or whatever you
have to and anything in life you have to
decide once you decide you're gonna do
it what things you will and want things
you won't do
that's the when I moved to LA and people
were telling me about TV and I always
knew I wasn't gonna do vitamin I always
knew I was gonna do I know I always know
I was gonna do it tonight show I always
know I wasn't gonna do Kimmel I accepted
that I always accepted the Doug Stanhope
rap iolite that he played the
underground comic I like that it felt
that's why when we started doing the
podcast I wanted I emphasized so much on
listening because I wanted people to
listen to the podcast I hope they listen
to something dirty like the the
government didn't let them listen I was
like listen to rock music and Cubans 79
it just wasn't allowed you know and it
was so weird that after I did the
generates on the plane right I went
through all these emotions for a few
weeks and I was angry I was mad I was
happy I was sad and that's why I tell
people you don't know what you got you
know you don't you better be careful
what you wish for because it just might
happen when I wished for a Netflix
special I didn't I was specific yeah
that's a big one
someone may contact me and said they
wanted me to be a part of something I
said yes off the bat and once I got
there you know I was like why are we
shooting in a pool when we have 2000
stages and vague
there's just so many little things that
worked against me you know I felt like
Netflix I just hated a bag of [ __ ] on
this special so till this day I'll say
that and I just moved forward I came up
with a different plan and this plan has
worked inform him more than the plan
before so once I did that and I realized
I didn't want to have it be put in that
position again that's it I don't want to
be put in that position again I'd rather
just do my spots at the Comedy Store all
these things I do when I stick to them
they work out for me you know it's like
I tell people when you make a decision
and you stick to it eventually
that thing will work out for you but you
have to stick to that decision once you
go away from that all the houses a cards
fall and you got to start all over again
you know years ago I used to get mad or
nobody ever puts me in movies stop doing
this on loud day movies when I stop
saying no to them nobody called me ever
again for them and I booked this
Stallone movie and I bought a couple
other movies why because I stopped doing
those you decide what you're not and
gonna do and they'll make your life that
much easier down the line later on you
know and that's why I didn't do the
festival I have nothing against necklace
I think Netflix
is a great company they gave a ton of my
friends a platform you know so when you
get into something like comedy art or
when you become a plumber you decide
somewhere along the line whether you
want to be a residential plumber a
commercial plumber a new construction
plumber you know do you want to rip
these walls down and find rats in there
okay so and you want the new
construction you know the saying we'd
have to find rats you know when I was an
electrician in Colorado I did new
construction and I loved it you know
very wants to know why you have to go
into crawl spaces oh that's where
everything is when electricity you have
to go through a crawl space any concern
in hospice then I could okay then I
could now is a different story
that's looking like I don't think it
classified I'm gonna forget working as
an electrician for one day in Hoboken I
hate books now where I broke down why
one day I was getting I think 15 when I
started in Aspen as an apprentice and
when I went to Hoboken New Jersey in 83
I figured I'd do electricity while I was
there and I went to one company and they
hired me in Hoboken and it was - it was
like when you got her when you got these
little brown stones I'll never forget
the guy going all right you go down
stands we shut the power and me hear him
like snakes and lizards and rats
crocodiles under there I was like I
gotta go for lunch the guy goes where
you going I gotta go get a soda I got
some in my throat or I walked up to that
thing and I got on that number 22 bus I
think that's the bus at Taste the
Hoboken from Union City the number 22 I
think that's it and I got out of that 22
and I never went to Hoboken again Doug I
forget that I got a job electrical
supply warehouse I'm not doing this no
more I'm not I knew that was it for me
you know I just you just you have to
decide what you're gonna do with what
you got you know and the same thing
those who stand up people think it's
better to want them to have sometimes
you know you gotta be careful what you
want what you wish for because it just
might come true but you have to be
specific yeah it sounds like like what
the resistance thing that we've talked
about what that punk how even if you
don't stick to your guns like stuff will
come up that seems good but it's really
getting in the way is that it's a law
diminishing Richard it's like a dear
dear friend of mine once told me
something he goes man I've been around a
lot of people and you're the only person
I know that when you say no you mean no
like it's you have to stick to your
guards in life you know it's really
weird when you stick to something
that's it this is what I'm doing this is
how I'm doing it and I'm gonna do it
like this until it breaks or until it's
proven to me that this doesn't work
that's how we do everything in this life
all of us you know when we finally were
spinning our wheels we go we're spinning
our wheels you know at least for me
that's how it's always worked
I've always caught on while I'm spinning
my wheels like something's not right
here you know with stand-up I'm like
anybody else when I got him to stand up
I did anything that was drawn at me I
never said no to anything anything for
the first till 2004 2000 2005 was when I
started saying know the things because I
had to I was it was it was too much I
was getting taken advantage of I just
want to be a good guy and get on state I
never cared about anything else but what
was in front of me being funny I never
cared about wearing that hat to be cool
or bringing the drink up onstage to be
cool sipping from my straw to be cool or
bringing a beer on that never
you don't need none of that your job is
to be funny that's it
everybody over you know what am I gonna
come up to what song am I gonna come out
to their sainted dance
this is stand-up comic but somewhere
along the line you forget and then you
get back on course you know and that's
it that's what I personally think about
that but no I have nothing against
Netflix I just know what I wanted to do
and I knew what I didn't want to do and
now who knows what's gonna happen with
this whole corona vid thing whatever
though you know like I said I just want
you people to I appreciate everything
you've done for me over here is
listening to the podcast supporting the
show you know laughing at my stupid
jokes on Twitter or whatever I wanted to
stay in that way I really care about you
guys man and
the reason I do this podcast is to let
you know you got this whatever people
tell you society tells you or whatever
you got this I don't care whatever you
got this you know how I know because
they told me a society told me a bunch
of things I couldn't do and guess what I
did them even though they told me I
couldn't do you got this so you know
stay vigilant these next couple weeks
keep your eyes open and just play it by
him and don't get down gettin down ain't
gonna have nobody you know you got
credit cards he use them not for stupid
stuff not for stupid stuff you know the
credit card companies are gonna give you
a break on payments now and stuff like
that use everything that's allowed to
you you know and that's stuff you can do
work online there's a lot of places that
you can do like if you're look at fiber
fiber has a bunch of stuff you can do
writing stuff edit stuff if you're an
artist you can tell your people still
need stuff done so there's a lot of ways
what's fiber fiber fiv ER are so anytime
i have any are working lightly done from
their instruction five bucks because you
can set your own prices and they people
do hundreds of things they they edit
writing they do video stuff it's it's
amazing it's from all over the world so
you can you have to sometimes check see
if they're from in India or whatever but
even even that I've done like ten things
to them I love it and you can say you
could make some money that way
you can do these uh surveys and make a
little bit of money online surveys you
could do it's not great but listen man
even if you just get no hamburger from
Wendy's you know for years I lived on a
double double menu you know the wopo not
the whopper the Wendy's Judy it's really
a bacon cheeseburger I take off the bird
the bacon bacon there and I have a cup
of chili and I eat a salad that was my
thing that had Wendy so don't let this
get you down
hang in there and that's basically it
man we covered it all today it's a
beautiful Monday and all I could tell
you is it's gonna be a beautiful [ __ ]
day to be alive but only you can ruin it
or make it worse you could make it
better stay in mind your business
listen the podcast grab your notebook do
push-ups you're in prison you're in
prison that's it
you always want to be a badass and go to
prison you're in prison that's what this
is all about now you do your push-ups
you do your setups you drink a lot of
water
give this a time to think think about
your future you know I looked at the
downside of this at first and then I
looked at the bright side of this this
is great this is great if you take care
yourself look out for your loved ones
and just you know know that there's
gonna be an out to this the most
important thing is you not getting
whatever is going around that's the most
important thing about this whole next
two weeks so please just mind your
business you don't you know yes I wrote
because that's what people gonna do did
I tell you I have the coronal I call
that get the hell out of my face
I don't even want to talk to you right
now you know save on time save on energy
when you go to the supermarket they say
facemask don't work I don't know if they
work or they don't but I'd rather be
safe than sorry
those guys were face masks on Sally
during the fight companion oh they just
took a picture with them I didn't see
that and watch the fight companion so I
didn't know what they were doing if
wrote about gloves I have gloves in the
car what kind of gloves like search with
an end they were all out of the other
ones prior I have a a boxing gloves like
plastic when I get like doctors and food
food prep people so like that's the case
yeah that's smart these are all my
things late you know I want you to be
around man and like I said refund
tickets I'm telling you I'm telling you
the truth get your money back you know
The Improv is closed on April 1st
so I know what you could do with the
improv but for right now get your money
back I'm not just from me from all these
steps get your money back
you know that's it we want our money
back we don't know what's gonna happen I
don't want nobody breathing on my neck
because I want to see some guy jump up
and down on stays I gonna [ __ ] watch
Netflix that's why you got Netflix for
watching my Netflix put YouTube on
there's no way you need to go save you
money you know if you got Motley Crue
tickets and all that get a refund it's
four hours you don't know what's gonna
happen there you don't want to be in no
arena and getting breathed on by some
exco vid because when they're gonna call
these people then once they get the co
vid dude what do you put on them do you
put like a bug on their head or
something like I had the vid whatever so
you don't know what you dealing in a
dark path I don't know something sure
you gotta put like a tattoo on there for
like ask what like ash wednesday i had
the cove is just to let you know man can
you imagine walking into a concert and
this guy just got out of a hospital bed
but he's too stupid to go through the
bunk period so he wants to go see ZZ Top
so he's jumping next year with Cobra
germs in July and you're like all this
is great
poison and next thing you know you're
gonna go home and you're gonna have
point now now we got a pic of it on
their forehead something to let us know
they had the vid I'm saying something
just running him over I'm telling you
not you can't run them over
I'm just saying scare me like a person
like walking like the yeah listen these
people it's not like them they're like
I'm walking dead it that would be great
if they're like walking dead cuz you get
them with the car and get away with it
but no I'm not talking about nobody of
the car that Lee put those words in my
mouth if you have the kovin I feel bad
for you but but if you're an ex-con feed
stay to yourself stay in your own corner
write a little tattoo on your head we
gotta put some monument to identify
these kovat [ __ ]
who had it because I don't want to be
bumping into them I don't be shaking
hands you had the vid that seems no
living here if you add the vid it's
gonna live in you for like a year and I
want no part of it so don't be touching
my chopsticks don't do nothing don't do
nothing
ah I'm so sorry about this ladies and
gentlemen
like we said we all have our breaking
points two weeks
listen but think about it anyway don't
think about none get your refund have a
great Monday uncle Joey loves you we'll
be back Wednesday with a fun one this
one is really gonna get you on Wednesday
so make sure you listen to this one
it's my man Sam triply dropping
knowledge as of right now I got no dates
okay it's over
I got April 20th at the store for 20 and
that's it that's all I'm doing right now
so don't even worry about nothing the
tour I don't know what's gonna happen
with the tour we're gonna wait on that
to see how many people drop dead and and
that's it that's all I can tell you
right now I hope I didn't offend nobody
I'm just trying to be as honest as I can
the church is also brought to you by zip
recruiter listen them hiring used to be
hard multiple job sites stacks of
resumes a confusing review process
background checks knock it off today
hiring can be easy and only you have to
go to one place to get it done you ready
grab a pen zip recruiter comm slash
Church
listen zip recruiter sends your job to
over a hundred of the web's leading job
sites but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply to your job
you can even add screening questions to
your job listing so you could filter out
candidates and focus on the best ones
like did you have covert 19th
you could even have that on there you
can't have that out there anyway do me a
favor go to zip zip recruit is so
effective that's four out of five
employees who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
and right now
shatrak zip recruiter for free the
church family can go to zip recruiter
calm slash church again that zip
recruiter dot-com slash church zip
recruiter comm slash Church for free zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire I
want to thank on it
I want to thank zip recruiter but most
importantly I want to thank you guys may
God bless you and look over you over
this trying time and we'll be back
Wednesday to rock your world
stay black have a great Monday don't let
times get you down I will be doing the
gas mask comedy this week one day we'll
figure it out we'll surprised you're
right
stay black stay healthy and have a great
Monday